the following program is brought to you
in living color on NBC some audio
portions have been previously recorded
my 45th annual Academy Awards
presentation
this is the plaza of the Music Center in
Los Angeles California which tonight is
a suburb of Hollywood since early
morning crowds have gathered to watch
the stars who arrived earlier for
tonight's ceremony Eddie Albert with son
Edward Albert emphasis Albert former
Oscar winner lovely greer garson Marisa
Berenson of Cabaret bearded and talented
james coburn deliverance star Burt
Reynolds with Dinah Shore lovely mrs.
Edward G Robinson Joel Grey Oscar
nominee and Best Supporting Actor
category for Cabaret Diana Ross for Lady
Sings the Blues
Jeannie Burley and Best Supporting
Actress nominee for Heartbreak Kid
here's Michael Caine nominated for his
starring role in sleuth glamorous elke
sommer Francis Ford Coppola Best
Director nominee for Godfather Cicely
Tyson Best Actress nominee for sounder
leave onin a nominee for the emigrants
and Billy Dee Williams star of Lady
Sings the Blues
I can't believe that Garbo went to work
at 5:00 a.m. and Chaplin to those famous
scenes at 7:00 but it's on this drafty
sad stage where this crazy work is done
from cabaret right back to seventh
heaven if it seems an inconvenience it
is not a total loss
well ask Miss Tyson Smith and woman miss
Minnelli and miss Ross first we get
together for the coffee
and the rolls then we throw to make up
on the face make a little magic we try
to make a little dream come true then we
make a beeline for the dryer and the
comb making sure that every year to play
make a little something then the most
important thing next to face and hair
call my dear designer in what am I to
wear
I love it defile
that's me
with the little Stardust and some
glamour
you
you
you
make a little magic that is what it's
all
of the Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences the Academy award-winning
screenwriter mr. Daniel taradash
company and our music director John
Williams good evening one of the vital
signs of an art is the enchantment it
holds for youth today the denim
generation is into movies in wildly
accelerating numbers in the United
States alone 613 colleges and
universities offer 2818 film courses
not to mention high schools and even
elementary schools
thus the Academy estimates but by the
end of the century there will be 1
million eight hundred and forty thousand
six hundred and five filmmakers in this
country therefore in the year 2000 when
we bring you the 72nd Academy Awards
instead of five nominees in each
category there will be 37 and this
program will run nine hours and 28
minutes another mark of vitality in an
art is the interest shown in it by the
general public
film is the most controversial the most
talked about the most reviewed art of
all movie critics and movie societies
abound proclaiming their 10 best lists
from here to Bombay but the judgments
are made mainly by people who can't
produce a movie or write or direct one
or edit one or compose music for one or
well tonight the professionals are the
reviewers the Academy is celebrating the
vitality of films by reviewing itself to
start us off a real professional mr.
Clint Eastwood
he's supposed to be Charlton Heston part
of the show but somehow he hasn't shown
up
so who they picked they picked the guy
who hasn't said but three lines in 12
movies to a substitute for Ida so if if
you don't mind yeah okay if you don't
mind I'll just keep this book next to me
so Heston is supposed to say something
about something biblical here referring
to him playing Moses and he says when I
brought the tablets down from the
mountain Cecil B DeMille research staff
assured me that there would be only ten
commandments see these people were wrong
they're 11 Commandments the 11th
commandment comes from the federal
communication system so spoke the
Commission thou shalt have full
disclosure come on flip the card man
this isn't my bag okay
in the book of Genesis was written at
the first day all eligible Academy
members are asked to vote for
nominations for the best picture of the
year on the second day the other
nominations are made
when I blow those tablets down from the
mountain Sookie Jim knows huh I should
have brought that staff there are 11 the
11th commandment comes from the Federal
Communications Commission thus spake the
commission thou shalt have full
disclosure in the book of Genesis it is
written that on the first day all
eligible Academy members are asked to
vote for nominations for the best
picture of the year on the second day
the other nominations are made by
members of the Academy branches
specialists in their fields afters
nominated actors film editors nominated
film editors and so on on a third day
these votes having begat the nominations
Academy members vote by secret ballot
for all the awards of Merit on a 4th day
they send their ballots directly to the
Academy's independent accountants the
three wise men Price Waterhouse and
company the results are known only to
these sages who speaketh in no tongues
to no man know how on a fifth day which
this year happens to be tonight
representatives of that firm will hand
the sealed envelopes containing the
winners names to the presenters and
behold the names will be revealed on a
sixth day the tinkling of symbols in the
gnashing of teeth
will echo through the Hollywood land and
a seventh day Pricewaterhouse in company
rests hallelujah and thus
sent the award for some a longtime star
who's been nominated this year for Best
Supporting Actor in the Heartbreak Kid
and a brand new star who played the
blind boy so movingly and butterflies
are free he's a two men who hardly need
to be introduced to each other
Eddie and Edward Albert
good evening I don't know what makes me
prouder tonight to be here the nominee
or here with my son the movie star movie
star huh he never told me that a movie
star has to get up at 5:00 in the
morning
Shamir funny yellow stuff all over their
face and remember lines in front of a
camera well now you know yeah I've never
heard a better definition of them with
but be patient be patient they're more
delectable dividends and wait for you
and I want to give you some advice
please not the judge Hardy Mickey Rooney
man-to-man routine uh I know that goes
yes I know you know about girls but you
don't know how to announce the nominees
for the best achievement in sound but
I'll bet you I'm gonna learn all right
what not yet oh I'll beg your pardon
they're not Thank You Frederick the the
nominations for the best in chief best
achievement in sound are that's you
Arthur Kenta though she and Charles
night four butterflies are free bro
Robert Knutson and David Hilliard in
cabaret Richard Portman and Jean
kanthamma say the candidate bud Grenn's
Bach Richard Portman Christopher Newman
for The Godfather
Theodore Soderbergh and Herman Lewis the
Poseidon Adventure and the winner is Oh
you have to open that okay I'll let you
do that yes the winners are Robert
Newton and David Hilliard for cabaret
accepting the award on behalf of Robert
mr. Robert Wilson
I was very fortunate working with some
very talented sound engineers this year
Richard Tyler and art piano dosey
without him have been very very tough on
behalf of them and Tadeo and David
Hilliard he wasn't able to be here this
evening they like very much to thank the
producers director Bob Fosse well the
time they allowed us to do this picture
time is something we don't get much of
anymore thanks to all them thanks the
Academy thank you very much